I recently had a screened mammogram and they want me to come back for a diagnostic mammogram
and possibly an ultrasound. So usually if you have a screening mammogram that they found
some lesions, so what an oncologist or a radiologist uses the term lesions, whether they're looking
at an X-ray or a mammogram or a CT scan or an MRI, they'll use the word lesions to say that
there's something going on that they saw abnormal on the scan. That doesn't mean a lesion like
you think of, like it has to be a tumor or something like that, but there's something abnormal there.
Certainly it could be a tumor, it could be cancer, but it suggests that we need to investigate
a little bit deeper. Then they may want to do a deeper diagnostic ultrasound and there's some
new type of 3D ultrasounds depending on where you're going that are 3D mammograms,
depending on where you're going that could get a better picture. There's some brand new technology out
that not very many places have that it's a totally different type of mammogram, which is actually
pretty neat and excited for that to come on the market. Then from there, if they still see that
this mass is suspicious, they may request to do an ultrasound guided biopsy. That's kind of the
progression with breast issues, and that's fairly normal. Now if you ultimately do want to find out
whether it's a cyst or it's a cancer, you have to get a biopsy. The only way to know
that you absolutely know whether it's cancer or not is to get a pathology report. You could only do
that through a biopsy. From a medical legal standpoint, you have to have a biopsy in order to have a
diagnosis. In order to have a cancer diagnosis, it has to be done via pathology report via biopsy.
This person goes on to ask about whether they can do a thermography. Is that helpful?
So if thermography is very helpful to see if there is metabolic activity, because thermography is
going to pick up heat, and you're going to have an increase in metabolic activity. That can be
very helpful, but if thermography is not going to be diagnostic of cancer, nor is it diagnostic,
that there's not cancer if the thermography is within normal limits. So a thermography is a
screening tool that you have to understand that. So you wouldn't say, okay, I don't want to do a
biopsy. Can I just use a tooth thermography? No. If you're free,
a mammography, and you said, I don't want to do a mammography. I want to just do thermography.
Then I would say, yeah, you can make those kind of decisions, those health care decisions. You don't
want to do mammography because they are radiation. And use thermography as your screening tool,
and then from that screening tool, go and do more comprehensive diagnostic tests like
ultrasounds, and or further on with biopsies if the thermography was positive.